you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside liv
moods and we are now on every thursday
instead of tuesday so mark your
calendars big game tonight live warriors
taking on the bucks and clay has
returned liv
did you watch his first game back
i did and you know what he was taking
shots left and right i thought we would
see obviously
less scoring from him just because he
was on a minutes restriction but you can
tell he's been waiting for this moment
he got the ball back in his hand the
fans are excited i know you're probably
excited so i'm excited to see how his
role on this team evolves over the next
few weeks and once draymond returns but
loving what i'm seeing so far
yes loving what i see so far warriors
fans are excited can't wait to get dre
back but as always we're giving out
hoodies
we're giving out jerseys and today we
are giving out
a pair of the new airpod max headphones
so get in the comments i need everybody
to get in the comments and give me gifts
give me emojis but most importantly liv
we need winners only please you guys
fill those comments up with winners only
please in fact right now liv i'm not on
the handy dandy ipad today i have the
handy dandy phone out and i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments looking for
takes i'm looking for good takes and
that's the only way you guys are getting
hoodies for good takes i got michael
bowling let's go splash brothers versus
the greek feet shout out to you mike
bowling uh i got minutes restriction hmm
i think they're talking about clay and
his minutes restriction and that is rob
gucci 2x4 shout out to you rob gucci 2x4
you're walking away with hoodie live the
producer just whispered into my ear and
said give away a jersey right now so ooh
i'm in the comments and i see enderman
enderman giving us a clay gift he has
the tropics uh
uh the the flint tropics jersey on so
shout out to my man enderman you are
walking away with a jersey uh liv are
you ready to get this show like
officially started
let's get it started i'm ready to go
let's let's get it started it's tnt
basketball thursday fanduel is boosting
the 3x2 and not one but both games
tonight the question is will there be
two three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game
last week the 3x2 in the celtics knicks
game
it cash let's take a look
there it is that's 48 from the top
yes sir
green dot like they do on 2k uh oh
let's that's another one that's another
one boy jaylen brown that's another one
uh
foreign that game holy mackerel yeah he
he he definitely was today we asked you
guys on twitter which three by two will
catch tonight is it the golden state
warriors taking on the milwaukee bucks
or is it
portland taking on libs denver nuggets
and here are the results
there it is and i am not
surprised by that liv uh we know who's
playing in golden state the splash
brothers are back but what i need you
guys to do is get in the comments and
tell us which 3x2 is a lock live talk to
the people talk to me which one is your
favorite
yeah normally i am one for fading the
public but tonight i'm riding with the
public i mean don't let the banner fool
you i love my nuggets absolutely but
right now they're too inconsistent and
the trailblazers are just far too
injured so i've got a ride with the
healthier team here and not to mention
both golden state and milwaukee ranked
top five for three-pointers attempted
and made i think this is a good
bounce-back spot for steph who was two
for nine from the three in his last game
versus the grizzlies lots of superstars
on this court i like this one to hit i'm
riding with the public giving me the
warriors and the bucks with the three by
two
i love when liv bring those statistics
into the three by two i like
i just love when she brings those
statistics and uh i'm in the comments
right now liv i'm in the comments giving
out hoodies and looking for takes i got
tyrell real no beast is in the comments
saying clay's about to eat tonight and
he have clay actually eating the
sandwich as a gift shout out to you real
no beast you were walking away with it
those are the type of though that that's
what we need that's what we need in the
comments uh enderman is back he says
golden state warriors versus milwaukee
he's riding with you live uh
i got one more in me i got one more emmy
alex north east la that's his username
northeast la he says golden state
warriors and milwaukee so guess what
everybody
i'm making the decision we are riding
with the golden state warriors and the
milwaukee bucks 3x2 tonight
so let's go let's get rich let's get
rich off the 3x2 hopefully clay and
steph can uh throw up some threes and
hopefully some bucks they can throw up
some threes in the first three minutes
as well but as we mentioned on the at
the top of the show liv my man the other
splash brother clay thompson is back so
today we asked you in the app how many
points will klay thompson score tonight
get in the comments and tell us what you
guys think
at the end of the game we're gonna dm
one random fan who guessed correctly and
hook you up with a pair of the new
airpod max's uh let's take a look at the
current odds clay's over under is
sitting at
14 and a half
liv
what do you think
anything else you like here
i mean i do like clay over tonight i
think that he is a solid duo with steph
curry um obviously no draymond green
still so clay is still kind of figuring
out his offensive role on this team and
i think he'll just get better and better
every game which i love but i also do
like giannis to have a big game he won't
be guarded by draymond he's averaging 33
points per game in the last five and i
think this is a good spot for him
because who is guarding him besides
draymond green i don't think anyone is
capable of guarding giannis outside of
draymond green on this warriors team so
i think it's a great spot for him he's
gonna carry that offensive load for the
bucks tonight and hit over 30 and a half
with ease so i'm taking his over
liv is rocking with johannes she's
rocking with the giannis over okay liv i
see you uh i mentioned clay uh over
under at 14 and a half actually the line
moved it's at 13 and a half that's even
better so that's
what i'm rocking with
even better i'm rocking with the klay
thompson over tonight 13 and a half
should be easy no draymond we will be
leaning on clay to score the ball uh
i'm in the comments right now i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies for takes i
got
boogie boogin
boog
nyts boogin ytes says clay he's going
for 16 tonight shout out to you you are
walking away with hoodie dave rose also
dave rose 2 says clay's going for 19
points tonight
shout out to both of you two you guys
are walking away with hoodies please
remember after the game we're going to
hit up one person and hook you up with a
new pair of air pot maxes liv it's time
for my favorite part of the show let's
talk major markets money lines against
the spreads and points totals for
tonight's game let's take a look at the
odds liv what are you seeing here and
what do you like
yeah i'm really liking under 211 in that
portland denver game lots of starters
out for the trailblazers as i've
mentioned earlier which makes scoring
for them difficult tonight and they are
also facing a denver defense that allows
the eighth fewest points to opponents
the nuggets right now are ranked bottom
10 in points scored per game tier it's
the truth it hurts my heart but it is
what it is 52 percent of portland's
games this season have gone under and 51
of denver's games this season have also
gone under so with so many players out
and the nuggets struggling to score but
still keeping solid defense i am riding
with under 211 in that game
liv's rocking with the under live i
don't know if you heard but i just got a
phone call it was vegas calling me and
letting me know to take the warriors
money line tonight
moneyline tonight uh
i'm gonna the reason is reason is is
because the warriors they only lost two
times in a row one time this year they
lost their last game in memphis it was a
hard fought game it was a hardball game
in memphis but i see the bounce back
tonight i see the bounce back tonight
in milwaukee they need it uh so give me
the warriors give me the warriors but i
am in the comments right now i'm in the
handy dandy uh iphone
and here we go i got xavier house in
portland is winning by 10. tonight
that's his favorite bet uh i bet those
odds will be good uh here we go of the
yov 707 says okay 18 easy for clay so he
says clay is going to score 18 that
means he's going over
that point total so shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you two are
walking away with a hoodie uh liv we
talked major markets now let's talk
player props it's time for lock or not
i'm gonna put up a prop and i need all
of you everybody in the comments
says get in the comments and tell me
whether it is a pro i mean it's a lock
or it is not are you guys ready live are
you ready
i'm ready to go let's do it
let's let's get right to it uh first up
there he is nicole yokish to score over
25 points liv is sitting at -114 this is
your nuggets he does play for your
favorite team live talk to the people
talk to me do you think that this is a
lock or not
oh yes oh yes it is a lock absolutely
right now the trailblazers give up the
third most points to opposing centers at
24 points per game however your pitch is
not your average center okay this is an
mvp center that we're talking about here
he has carried this denver offense
alongside will barton since all of their
starters have been injured recently but
tonight will barton is not playing so
that means the load falls on yokoch's
shoulders he can handle the pressure
he's averaging 28 against this
trailblazers team so 25 plus should be
easy money tonight absolutely a lock
liv
you mentioned will barton not in the
lineup tonight i think that's going to
lead to more opportunities for your boy
down low uh so i'm rocking with you man
this is your team
he
he's a the mvp like you said the mvp of
you guys team uh so i'm rocking with you
i think he can go get 25 tonight let's
move on let's move on liv this one um is
kind of dicey we got ben mclemore yeah
to make
five three pointers live it's sitting at
plus 160. i do not like this at all that
is my take liv talk to me do you like
this or do you not
no i no i really don't i mean listen he
has been playing better than earlier in
this season because he is getting more
valuable playing time aka he's putting
up more three-point shots he's making
some of them i know he had five last
game however he's facing a denver's team
whose opponents have the ninth lowest
three-point percentage five is a lot of
threes he's only hit that over in one of
the last five
so
i don't love it i think the value is
plus 160 for a reason it's not my
favorite play i'm going to say not a
lock
yeah liv i i think like you said it's
plus 160 for a reason i think the odds
makers think that this one is not a lock
that's why we have it at plus 160 but
finally
let's move
on to nurkic but before before we move
to nurkic i'm so sorry i gotta get in
the comments i gotta get in the comments
again
i gotta get in the comments and give my
people some some hoodies man this is why
they come i got um
northeast la is back in the comments
saying faye ben mclemore i do not blame
you uh snoopy
2153 says nah can't trust five hits i i
i agree with you snoopy i can't put my
money on ben mclemore making five uh i
got beasty beasty j6 says no shot
ben stays that hot so no shot ben stays
that hot uh they're saying no shot that
he's hitting
those five threes they're agreeing with
me and you live but let's move on
finally to nurk
to grab 12 or more rebounds and then
sitting that plus 190 live
it's a lot that's a lot of plus money
right there it's a lot of plus money but
talk to the people do you like this
going against
joker and the nuggets
no i really don't and to be honest with
you this is one of those moments where i
may be betting with my heart a little
bit because i have been burned by nerve
itch way too many times and yeah i mean
in my opinion he is a betting liability
i don't know what version of him i'm
gonna get on any given night one second
he's a rebounding machine the next he's
playing scared soft basketball you
cannot play scared when you are facing
an mvp center in nicola yokitch you will
get eaten alive and i don't see him
being a rebounding machine going
head-to-head with jokish tonight he's
only averaged six and a half boards
against denver this season i know he's
hit this over in four of the last five
but it's a different story when you're
facing jokic so i would say not a lot
tonight
yeah liv you brought up a good point
he's facing the joker and the joker is
also a good rebounder 12 rebounds is
having a game that's having a real good
game for my guy uh for my guy nurkic so
i think i'm gonna rock with you liv i
think i'm gonna rock right there with
you uh and say no to the 12 rebounds
today uh i'm in the comments though i'm
in the comments you guys are dropping
locks you guys are dropping takes uh let
me see enderman is back enderman says no
no lock northeast la is back he says no
lock oh my god killa kells killakel says
not today that's from winners only i see
that not today shout out to you killer
kells you're walking away with a hoodie
um one more
rail no bus says no he's not nurkic may
get three or five rebounds only shout
out to everybody that i mentioned you
guys are walking away with hoodies live
it's time to build the br betting custom
same game parlay which you can ride
along with us
on fanduel last week live
celtics knicks parlay
we cashed over plus 400
so we're gonna try to keep the streak
going we're gonna try to keep the good
vibes going and speaking of parlay's
live three friends through 50 cents each
on this first basket score parlay last
night turning 50 cents into over 130k
lift
per person
not combined but per person
i know you're going on i know you're
going on a vacation soon liv do you and
your friends ever uh
get together and come up with parlays
like this
i mean i'm sure we do but they don't hit
you know it's one of those things where
you could throw a bunch of things
together and you love that value and
you're like oh could you imagine but you
never actually think it's going to
happen and here's where i have the most
respect for these guys is first basket
scorers there is no way to handicap that
i don't care how good of a handicapper
you think you are there's no way to
handicap that so they're just they're
just on the right side of fate at that
point and they need to go now apply for
the powerball and the lottery because
luck is on their side right now and
congrats to them because that's a whole
lot of money so i'm impressed that is a
whole lot of money uh we need those good
vibes here we need those good vibes here
because i'm about to give out our
par lay i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me what you guys think
tell me which legs are locked tell me
which legs or not
tonight we're looking at the warriors
taking on the bucks game live are you
ready to get to it
let's get to it i'm ready to go let's
let's get right to it all right first
off we talked about them earlier in the
show my guy clay thompson
to score
two or more three pointers tonight live
talk to me nice please talk to me nice
do you like this one or do you not
yeah i mean i know i said earlier that i
was kind of concerned because i didn't
know what his offensive role was quite
yet on this team but here's what i do
know he will take the shots in a
combined 40 minutes of playing time in
just two games he has had 13 three-point
attempts he's gonna take the shot now
it's a matter of whether it hits and
here's the deal being guarded by grayson
allen does not scare me for clay at all
so i do like this leg he's gonna take
the shots he's gonna hit two plus i like
this a lot for him tonight
all right we got the live approval on
the clay three pointers love that let's
move on to the next
the next leg of the parlay it's my guy
the other splash brother live
steph curry 25 plus points tonight he's
been uh i would say on steph curry terms
he's been shaky i know he just had a
triple double last game against the
grizzlies but you know steph got high
standards everybody has high standards
of stuff and he's been playing you know
not to those standards as of late but
do you think he can go get 25 points
tonight
so here's how i think this is gonna play
out i think we're gonna sweat it out
we're gonna sweat it out it's gonna be
half time we're gonna go oh i don't
think he's gonna hit it and he's gonna
come out of the gates halftime and just
do what he does best this is a great
bounce-back spot for him um and on any
given night when he gets hot there is no
stopping him and i think he is the type
that rises to the occasion he knows he's
facing the bucks that is a really good
team the warriors need another win
tonight uh you know after their loss
against the grizzlies so i think it's a
good spot for him and i think he hits
this
i like that in order for the warriors to
win steph curry has to score 25 points
tonight tonight he does
in recent games the warriors been okay
with steph not scoring they've still
been able to win but tonight no draymond
steph needs to score 25 in order for
them to win let's move on to the next
leg of the parlay i know you're going to
like this one because you mentioned it
earlier we got ianas onto thecupos
scoring 30 plus tonight live
we already know you like this one right
i do
let's let's go we got the live approval
for the giannis so we don't even need to
talk like we got live approval already
so let's go to the last leg let's go to
the last leg let's go to the last like
my guy chris middleton
whoo i have to take a deep breath right
here liv because six assists chris
middleton i mean i know he's kind of
he's kind of developed into like a a
play maker last year but do you think he
can go get six today
yeah i mean here's the deal like i said
earlier the reason that i'm on giannis
tonight taking the over on his points is
who's guarding him tonight i don't think
anyone is i think he is kind of the guy
that the offense the ball needs to be in
his hand as much as possible and who is
getting him the ball it's a guy like
chris middleton chris middleton has that
leadership to be a facilitator and to
trust giannis to put the ball in the net
so i like chris middleton to feed the
ball to be honest all night long this
leg has a chance to hit do i think we'll
be sweating it out
absolutely i do but i think it's a good
play
i see what you did liv but you you
you're just connecting the dots you you
know you honestly yeah
who's going to give him the ball chris
exactly come on i'm right here i'm right
here with you liv is connecting the dots
hopefully this parlay can connect the
dots tonight just like last week uh
let's pull up the ticket let's pull up
the odds and let's see what this could
do if we were to put a hundred dollars
down there it is you guys are walking
away with 508 dollars and 48 cents if
you was to put 100 down on our same game
parlay liv before i get into the
comments
what are you grading the same game
parlay
all right i mean i have personally been
on a little nba heater myself our parlay
cash last week i do really like this
parlay
i'm gonna give it an a minus the only
reason i'm not giving it an a or an a
plus is because you know what happens
when you start feeling too confident and
gambling the betting gods come down and
they humble you a little bit and we
don't need that tonight they will we
don't need that tonight we need winners
only please as greg would say so
a minus a minus to stay humble but i
love the parlay so it's still it's still
up there with a passing grade over
student for sure but an a minus just to
be safe
hey a minus we will take that uh it's
time to get into the comments because
i'm giving away a hoodie and i'm also
giving away a jersey here liv uh i got
sports feed sports feed says clay with
two threes please
you know what sports feed
just for the vibes just for the vibes
i'm gonna give you the jersey sports
feed you're walking away with a jersey
i'm back into the comments back into the
comments live uh i got
landon foss 18 says they all will hit
thank you for the vibe you were walking
away
with a hoodie uh one more for the people
at home live one more for the people
watching i got not steph curry says
warriors are getting the dub tonight you
know i like that so
you're walking away with a hoodie as
well liv the grizzlies are on a 10-game
winning streak
with job marant making an mvp run i know
that makes you so excited i need you
guys at home to get in the comments and
tell me if you think the grizzlies can
in fact win it all
and if not tell me your locks to win the
championship let's take a look at the
latest odds nets and warriors still are
the favorites
and on the second page live the second
page we have the grizzly sitting at plus
4200
what do you think of that play liv is
the grizzlies
title content
i mean here's here's what i love about
this i i love that vegas is continuing
to sleep on this grizzlies team because
that only means i get better value on
them the fact and here this is my team
so i can't even believe i'm saying it
the fact that the grizzlies are behind
the nuggets right now is despicable okay
i understand the nuggets have jokic the
nuggets have been blowing 20 to 30 point
leads in the third and fourth quarter
alone absolutely no reason that the
grizzlies should be behind them i love
that people are sleeping on the
grizzlies i don't think the grizzlies
have given anyone any reason to not
believe in them but to be honest with
you i think we're scared to believe in
them i don't know if we're going to
continue to get this grizzlies team at
this great of value because i think
they're going to continue to win games
this is the type of team that won
without john moran and is still winning
with john moran this is not a a dig at
your team because you know i'm all on
the warriors this year as well but with
draymond green they're a completely
different team and you can't guarantee
that your entire team will be healthy in
the playoffs this grizzlies team
continued to win without john moran so
they have that depth and that
competitiveness and that excitement to
them that i think will carry them very
far so if you see any potential in this
team at plus 4200 you may not get that
value again i think it's worth a
sprinkle absolutely
liv
you you you got a fair point on this
sparkle you mean if you got money to
blow still love the warriors
you you could throw you could throw it
on the grizzlies if you got money to
blow you know if you're sprinkling money
just go you can put it on the grizzly if
you want to
but i mean let's let's let's let's let's
come back into this box and let's talk
because grizzlies
i just think i just think that they're
they're they're a couple years away i
mean in the playoffs you know when when
coaches go up against each other if
matchups become a problem uh uh
adjustments become a problem and in a
seven game series i just don't think
that this grizzly team is ready this
year to compete in the west maybe in two
years maybe in three years but right now
i would not put my money on this
grizzlies team in fact you guys at home
should know where i'm putting my money
on those that is those golden state
warriors we just got clay back
james wiseman is in talks of coming back
i know glyph i i know i know the
warriors just recently lost to this
memphis grizzly team with no draymond
but like i said in the series in a
series where a team is facing each other
you know on on on a a night to night or
if it's not night tonight it's every
other night basis uh i just see the
adjustments i i being a problem and and
i see superstars the grizzlies they
don't have enough superstars in my
opinion to compete in the playoffs so
i'm rocking with the warriors i'm
staying with the warriors i've been on
the warriors since the beginning of the
year and my mama always told me if it
ain't broke don't fix it the warriors
ain't been broke this year so i'm not
fixing nothing and i'm sticking to my
roots and i'm rocking with the warriors
but
it's not about who i'm rocking with it's
about who the people are rocking with
because i'm in the comments right now
i'm in the comments
giving away hoodies uh i got
goat garden says warriors if everybody
is healthy will win shout out to you go
gardener you are walking away landon
landon is in the commons lift and he's
rocking with you he says he can see the
grizzlies winning the championship shout
out to you landon uh i got
smittyboy22 says he got a luca smiling
gift
in the in the comments uh live he has a
luca smiling gift i think he's uh
talking about them dallas mavericks
potentially winning uh the championship
i got one more in me
one more in me uh
xavier house says it's too easy dubs in
five against brooklyn he has a draymond
green gift going i'm not being biased on
the comments i promise you i'm reading
the comments that the people are uh
typing in but i mean
yeah the people are rocking with the
warriors i'm rock with the warriors live
tomorrow who are are you rocking with
the grizzlies is it official like are
you with the grizzlies or you have
another favorite team to win it all
i mean i've got john moran as my mvp
choice i grabbed him at plus 3200 so
i'll walk away with 3 200 if it wins so
i think i just gotta rock with him i'm
not again you know i love the warriors
i'm gonna keep rocking with them as well
but i'm not yeah you know i
warriors and and and grizzlies i can't
even believe it because the denver is in
the west but those are the two teams i'm
rocking with right now
liv honestly honestly you mentioned i
know you mentioned before job for mvp i
actually like that right now right now
at this very moment
i like that you mentioned that weeks ago
so i know this grizzlies team and john
moran i know they mean something to you
so i i don't dislike your mvp vote for
john marant uh but you did mention my
warriors and winning the championship so
i can agree with that uh but
the time has come liv
the time has come it's the end of the
show
thank
everybody for tapping into the group
chat presented by vandal please remember
what you learned today
the three by two in the warriors game is
a lot that's what we're riding with uh
i also think that the warriors are gonna
win the game they're gonna beat the
bucks so you guys can sprinkle some
money on that it should be plus money
but make sure you guys get on fanduel to
tell our br betting same game parlay
we'll be back next thursday giving out
more hoodies giving out more jerseys
giving out more locks and if you want a
hoodie today we will dm you do not be
alarmed we will dm you alongside live
moods i'm greg ivey we
are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
you